tout d'abord je tiens à saluer le
travail effectué par la Dom pour
accompagner les mobiles les mobilités
des résidents des Outre-mer mais
malheureusement je tiens à soulever une
injustice qui perdure depuis trop
longtemps les aides à la continuité
territoriale sont censées couvrir 40% du
prix du billet d'avion c'est un taux et
non pas un menton j'ai effectué donc
quelques recherches pour préparer le
rendez-vous d'aujourd'hui et dans tous
les cas de figure les familles
guyanaises auront toujours un reste à
charge supérieur à celui de famille
antillaise la faute bien entendu au
tarif pratiqués par les compagnies
aériennes qui desservent la Guyane
je rappelle que la moitié de la
population guyanaise vit sous le seuil
de la pauvreté et un tiers vit en
situation de grande précarité alors que
la Guyane a besoin d'avoir des forces
vives formées pour assurer son
développement trop de jeunes renoncent à
poursuivre leurs études en raison des
coûts exorbitants tous les sénateurs ici
ont tenté d'infléchir l'inflation sur le
prix des billets d'avion mais sans
succès je me tourne donc vers vous
monsieur le Président de la Dom que
pouvez-vous faire pour diminuer le reste
à charge des familles guyanaises et j'ai
une deuxième question les étudiants sont
de plus en plus nombreux à étudier plus
longtemps certains vont même jusqu'à 30
ans les causes sont nombreuses par
exemple que d'informations lors de
l'orientation année de césure a
répondraison familiale ou sociales
est-ce que vous pensez pas que la Dom
devrait relever l'âge maximum pour
déposer un dossier puisque l'âge maximum
il me semble que c'est 26 ans
ident dit que sur la région anti Guyane
et donc effectivement qui prend en
compte le prix du billet d'avion
sur ça il y a deux points d'amélioration
ce qui nous travaillons le premier c'est
qu'il était voté une augmentation du
plafond donc il restera un taux fixe et
qui aura vocation du coup à en moyenne
ne plus couvrir que 40% mais 50% en
moyenne puisque effectivement comme ça
au fixe ça dépend des périodes le
deuxième levier clairement qu'il faut
activer ce qui nous travaillons c'est de
faire en sorte que les compagnies sur
notamment les billets aidés par la Dom
puissent
puis dans le mot plafonner sûrement
peut-être le prix du billet pour qu'au
moins le reste à charge soit sur mon
temps limité alors pour cela il y a deux
solutions la première c'est qu'elle joue
le jeu donc ce qu'elles ont ce que nous
faisons nous avons rencontré tous les
compagnies plusieurs reprises et il y a
clairement une volonté de trouver des
solutions notamment pour un public très
précaire qui est le public éligible
l'autre peut-être levier qui est
peut-être plus commercial c'est
peut-être que la Dom aussi change la
façon de procéder actuellement la Dom
émet un bon qui permet à chaque individu
de voyager avec la compagnie qu'il
souhaite dans les compagnies pour le
coup n'ont pas une raison particulière
peut-être qu'il faudrait
le Parlement non choisir un opérateur ou
une compagnie parmi d'autres faire
parler vulgairement faire un deal et
peut-être qu'on échange d'un volume
garanti sur une durée enfin qui pour le
coup elle est assez incompréhensible
c'est que malgré ses effectivement le
public ne voit pas l'aide moi les
personnes me disent c'est gentil de
m'aider au final je voyage pas donc tu
pourrais m'aider à 1000 euros 10000
euros s'il me reste à payer mon temps
supérieur à ce que je peux je peux aider
donc je voyage pas effectivement il y a
un sujet que soulevait Monsieur le
Directeur c'est sur le le périmètre
d'aide effectivement certaines personnes
qui doivent venir du fleuve pour pouvoir
prendre l'avion à Cayenne les coûts
transports entre leur domicile et
l'aéroport peuvent être conséquent qu'on
vient de la Guyane ou même de Mayotte en
périphérie effectivement donc il y a un
sujet quand même sur le périmètre est-ce
que le l'aide commence à l'aéroport ou
est-ce qu'il faut pas dans certains cas
son territoriale qu'elle commence au
domicile quand on sait que le coût de
transport entre le domicile et
l'aéroport est quand même important
donc sur l'âge effectivement je pense
que vous avez raison et donc aussi nous
partageons cela effectivement le les
habitudes font que les gens
rentrent en formation plus tardivement
et effectivement il y a maintenant des
cursus de plus en plus long et donc et
notamment dans la volonté de permettre
aux gens de commencer le cursus dans le
territoire premier cycle deuxième cycle
de finir en hexagone ou ailleurs
effectivement il y aura un vrai sujet de
pouvoir élargir l'âge peut-être pas sur
le tout-venant mais au moins dans un cas
nos projets professionnels où il y a une
formation complémentaire en troisième
cycle ou même dans les phrases
complémentaires effectivement de
derrière l'arche une piste de travers ce
qui nous travaillons au jour
d'aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on a comme
moyen qui ont été augmentés je le
rappelle par le ministre sur cette
question de de
on fait on fait ce qu'on peut vraiment
on peut on fait ce qu'on peut et on
prend en sorte en 2024 d'abord cette
approche territorialisée dont parler
d'ailleurs madame la scène intriz con
conne il me semble être à mon avis la
meilleure approche pour justement coller
aux spécificités des territoires et
typiquement pour la Guyane on est chose
qui est spécifique par rapport à la
Martinique et la Guadeloupe qui se
rapproche beaucoup plus